in the last movie we talked about data
science without actually having big data
in this movie we'll take the complement
of that
we'll look at scenarios in which a
person works with big data
but doesn't require the full data
science skill set
as a way of reminding ourselves big data
usually involves unusual volume
and velocity and variety in the data
data science also has this little
diagram
it involves statistical skills and
domain knowledge and coding ability
and the three of them together gets data
science
now let's take a look at can you do big
data with just two of the data science
skills
how about with just statistics and with
coding
the answer of course is yes because
that's where we have machine
learning machine learning is a very
important area of data science
and this is where a computer program
learns to adapt to new information as it
comes in
the two most familiar examples are spam
filters where the computer program
learns that a particular kind of email
is spam or not
based on your own individual responses
and based on the responses of millions
of other people who use the same
email program or facial recognition in
photographs where your computer program
learns what face belongs to whom
here is an article from nature that
talks about artificial intelligence and
machine learning in general
if we scroll down a little bit it talks
specifically about the problem of facial
recognition
and how the computers can learn to
identify face
it is something that is very easy for
humans to do but much harder for a
computer
so machine learning is a good example of
working with big data
because it can have volume velocity
and variety but you don't necessarily
need to have domain knowledge
because the computer is working without
any knowledge whatsoever
another possibility is what drew conway
who created this venn diagram
originally called the data zone that's
the combination of coding
and domain knowledge without statistics
now he says
danger here but there are some very good
examples of data science here that do
not involve statistical
knowledge the most common of which are
word counts and just parsing of natural
language
the most common tool used for this is
what's called the natural language
toolkit
this is a package that's used in python
the programming language
and it will ask people to do all sorts
of amazing things
you can do things like word counts the
best known word count was the one that
was used actually a few decades ago to
identify authorship of the federalist
letters in american historical political
science
all the way up to the things like
comparing vocabulary sizes of various
hip-hop singers
and so there's amazing things that can
be done with natural language by simply
counting how often the words occur
without requiring any statistical
knowledge because there's no influential
procedure that goes into it
those are two of the combinations of
data science skills that we have two at
a time without big data
that leaves a third one here and that
statistics and substantive
or domain expertise and this is
traditional research
unfortunately without the coding skills
you're not going to be able to deal with
the volume the velocity
or the variety of data that
characterizes big data
tremendous things are accomplished in
traditional research but big data is not
one of them
in summary as far as you have at least
two of the items in the venn diagram
you can work with big data you cannot
work with big data
if you have just statistical knowledge
or just coding skills
or just domain knowledge instead what
you would have to do in that situation
is collaborate with people who have that
information and skills
in fact collaboration really is the rule
in data science
because there is such a broad range of
skills that are necessary
nobody is usually able to bring olive to
it but they have to work together
that actually is one of the wonderful
things because i think that most of the
interesting developments come about
through collaboration
and that is something that data science
encourages strongly
and so when you look at the relationship
between data science and big data
the situation isn't exactly even it's
possible to do data science with an
incomplete version of big data but it's
much more difficult to do
big data work without the triumvirate of
data science skills